gráfica e igualados entre 7 por equis y
además responde cuáles de las siguientes
proposiciones son verdaderas bueno
tenemos esta gráfica que tenemos que
ajustar para que se adecue a esta
ecuación esta es una relación
proporcional porque es de la forma que
igual a una constante en este caso 2
entre 7 por equis su gráfica va a ser
una línea recta pero primero vamos a
graficar la ecuación y tenemos que
encontrar dos puntos que pertenezcan a
esta ecuación qué pasa si yo aquí pongo
x cero pues el valor de lleva a ser
igual a cero así que pongo esto aquí en
cero cero muy bien necesito otro punto
quiero encontrar un punto desde yen que
sea entero y me convenga
esta es una fracción y bueno pues para
poder quitar esta fracción le conviene
que x sea igual a 7 para que se cancele
con el denominador aquí
y si x 17 esto se cancela y me queda que
es igual a 2 así que buscó x 7 y
igualados y esa es la gráfica de mi
ecuación bueno ahora vamos a ver los
enunciados estas proposiciones la
primera la ecuación de presentar una
relación proporcional esta es verdadera
ya lo habíamos establecido por el
formato que tiene esta ecuación así que
ésta es verdadera la segunda la tasa de
cambio unitaria de con respecto a x es
siete medios veamos la tasa de cambio
unitaria de ye con respecto a x es el
valor de g que corresponde a x igual a 1
así que la tasa de cambio unitaria si x
sustituyó aquí igual a 1 pues va a ser
dos séptimos y aquí nos dice que es 7
medios lo cual no es correcto esto no es
verdadera la pendiente de la recta es
dos séptimos esto es evidente ya que
esta ecuación es la de una recta
el formato de manera que este factor que
multiplica x y que todo es igual a james
es la ecuación de una recta así que esta
es verdadera veamos lo siguiente un
cambio de siete unidades en x como estas
siete unidades en x resulta en un cambio
de dos unidades engine y aquí lo estamos
viendo tenemos aquí nos movimos siete
lugares en x y al mismo tiempo
recorrimos dos lugares en y hacia arriba
así que ésta también es verdadera la
última un cambio de seis unidades en x
resulta en un cambio de 21 unidades en y
veamos si me mueva aquí en x 6 unidades
lleno va a valer 21 para nada que va a
valer 1.8 1.9 algo así entonces esta es
falsa comprobamos la respuesta y en
efecto esta es correcta